welcome to thick boy fighters let's dive
in in a video posted to instagram
heavyweight tom aspinall gave his fans
an update on his knee injury aspinall
injured the knee last saturday 15
seconds into his main event fight with
curtis blades aspinall detailed the next
step of his recovery which include an
mri scan and surgery
hello everybody
just a quick update on the knee
situation
because plenty of people are asking
about the diagnosis of what happened to
the knee
now anybody who's got knee problems
knows
that in order to have an mri scan an
accurate mri scan
you need to let the swelling go down
so i spoke to the surgeon
we have a rough idea of what it is
but
we are currently waiting for the
swelling to go down
and i will be having the mri scan this
weekend and having surgery
early next week in london
so just want to say massive thank you to
everyone who's reached out obviously
i've been offline been down in the dumps
since saturday night but
hopefully
we'll uh
get it fixed get the surgery early next
week thank you francis nagano's coach
eric nixik gave an update on naganu's
recovery while appearing on mma junkie
according to nick six comments it may
not be much longer until fans see the
heavyweight champ fighting again
i think he's either ahead of schedule or
on track one or the other and from what
i've gathered he's making great strides
he's back in the gym moving around
hitting pads and stuff nick sick
continued by sharing the most difficult
thing about coaching the ganu through
the injury the biggest thing for me as a
coach what i miss out on is time of
growing areas that we can improve on
that's where i get like oh man we're not
doing enough x y z and i'm okay with
that we don't have a fight lined up or
anything right now his main focus is
getting his knee rehab to the point
where he can get back in the lab and
start doing these things again hopefully
and it sounds like for what he's saying
that if something were to happen it
would be the end of the year or early
2023.
on wednesday the abc association of
boxing and combative sports passed two
changes to the unified rules of mma the
two changes were voted on at the 2022
abc conference and passed unanimously
the first rule change increased the
recovery time for fighters dealing with
an eye poke fighters will now be granted
five minutes to recover after an eye
poke the same amount of time allotted
for drawing strikes if the fighter is
not ready after five minutes expire the
fight will be called off the second rule
change allows for neoprene sleeves to be
worn by competitors mma junkie reported
the official rule change to be
a competitor may use soft neoprene type
sleeves to cover only the knee or ankle
joints approved sleeves may not have
padding velcro plastic metal ties or any
materials considered to be unsafe or
that may create an unfair advantage
neoprene sleeves are not considered
equipment or clothing and may not be
grabbed advantageously inside or as
clothing that can be grabbed by self
tape and gauze or any materials other
than the approved sleeves are not
permitted on the lower body the sleeves
must be black in color with the
exception of matching the athlete's
commission assigned corners with the
sleeves being blue or red or colored as
appropriate at the ufc 277 pre-fight
press conference ahead of his interim
title bout against brandon moreno kai
kara france spoke about the last time he
shared the octagon with moreno a
decision lost at ufc 245
you know the car that fought brandon
back in 2019 is in the same car they're
standing in front of you today
i've got so much more experience now
being a father being a husband i've got
more purpose and i'm just on another
level so you know congrats for brandon
for what he's done since we've fought
you know going on to win the title uh
but it's my time so you know
you know dallas texas i love being out
here you know i'm a long way from home
but i'll show you why i'm the best in
the world when asked whether he expects
a different version of the moreno he
previously fought kaikoura france
responded
you know brandon's the most dangerous
weapon is his mindset you know this
guy's a dog and i expect it to be a dog
fight so
comes here today we'll find out
at the press conference amanda nunez
laid out her plan to defend her
featherweight belt if she defeats the
bantamweight champion giuliana pena on
saturday when asked whether she would
consider challenging nunez for the 145
pound belt pena responded all the real
fights are at 135 she's saying that she
is going to fight at 145 and defend her
belt against who name three 145ers name
two 145ers there's nobody in that
division everybody knows the real fights
are at 135 pounds amanda and i are the
two best female fighters in the world
and all the real [ __ ] is at 1 35. pena
then gave a graphic description for what
fans can expect tomorrow night when the
octagon door closes i'm going to punch
kick pull her hair i'm going to bite her
i'm going to gouge her eyeballs out if i
have to i'm literally going to do
everything in there trust me when i say
i'm willing to die and do whatever it
takes i'm going to do whatever it takes
the ufc 277 weigh-ins were held friday
with all fighters on the main card
making weight women's bantamweight
champion juliana pena made a stir when
she waited until the last 90 seconds of
the weigh-in window to step on the scale
video courtesy of mma junkie the ufc
bantamweight champion the venezuelan
vixen julianna
[Music]
two early prelim fighters however did
not make their weight orion kosei
weighed two and a half pounds over his
170 pound limit and will forfeit 20
percent of his purse in his bout against
mike mathetha jocelyn edwards missed her
135 pound limit when she tipped the
scales at 137 and a half pounds she will
also forfeit 20 of her purse during his
visit to thick boys studios ufc
lightweight contender michael chandler
gave his exclusive picks for ufc 277 to
the thick boy fight news team
you can never bet against the beast
derrick lewis he's the man pavlovich is
very tough he's surging and i'm taking
derrick lewis kykar of france versus
brandon moreno brandon moreno being the
former champion this is for the antrim
belt never bet against kai kar francis
he's a tough kiwi from new zealand but i
think brandon moreno is just too
confident too good everywhere moreno
gets it done julianna pena versus amanda
nunes how do you ever
say that that that wasn't a fluke on the
first one so many people pena has came
out won the title but goodness gracious
amanda nunes has looked and been the
most dominant female fighter that we've
ever seen i'm going i think amanda nunes
gets her title back looking for more
original mma content check out the rest
of thick boy youtube exclusive
interviews opinion and fight analysis is
available weekly on the shob show food
truck diaries and fight night flashbacks
subscribe so you don't miss any of the
action
you